he's going to be indicted in Georgia and  I think he's going to be indicted by the  feds I think they've got the evidence we  don't know exactly what a lot of these  cooperating Witnesses are saying and I  think that you've got someone like Mark  Meadows who's probably the weak link and  if you're looking for the one witness  the most likely to turn I would vote him  the most likely to turn so  if this happened  what happens in the United States  because this would be a very very very  big deal  if a former president were to be  indicted  there would be a number of issues that  would have to be overcome first and  foremost  who sits on the jury and as I've said  before if you had someone like Trump in  front of a jury how do you find a jury  that is not going to be subject to  appeal because of the preconceived  notions and biases of those jurors